big changes coming to one of the major
players in the strip wynn resorts plans
to do a full remodel of the rooms within
the year
and bring a special experience to a
legion stadium
a news now reporter madison kimbrough
joining us with more on both ventures
yes this is really exciting news is one
of the biggest resorts that you can see
behind me is expanding
and it couldn't come at a better time as
customers start coming back
people are so happy to be back wynn
resorts is ready to expand
and remodel ahead of what's expected to
be a very busy
2022. conventions work customers are
excited and as
more restrictions are lifted and we're
able to really start to roll out our
entertainment and our nightclubs
in july a 200 million dollar remodeling
project will start in the resort's hotel
rooms
it will mark the first room renovation
in more than a decade
people we spoke to visiting vegas say
they welcome the change
they have to update you have to keep on
innovating and being
attractive to the public and
customers so if it's
renovating for it to for the better i'm
all
for after that and it wouldn't be vegas
without rolling out a brand new
nightclub experience
this one will be created by wind resorts
at allegiant stadium
i think it's amazing you know that
especially at the new stadium
i think it'd be a big draw and it's
going to already have a lot of interest
it sounds like a great idea to some but
not everyone i think that'd bring
in the wrong crowd and i think it'll say
something
i don't think it'll make the statement
that the wind would want in any case
wynn resorts is hedging its bet
on the majority being excited by the
idea of the 11 000 square foot win
field club and the club will require
reservations but those in the know say
that this club will offer
over the top access you can only get
here in vegas reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now